all right well we're going with an e4
and he pre-moves to sicilian okay
we've been playing the alopen a time and
i'm kind of tired of it
and um on this speedrun we've mostly
been playing the open sicilian so let's
let's
well we could also play the smith
tomorrow which is something we haven't
played much i don't know the smith
warrior too well though
but let's do it let's try it all right
i'm game for this myth more
i'm totally game for the smith bar the
problem is okay so he goes d6
and our choice is immediately justified
d6 is a bad move
uh so our opponent i assume is not very
confident
in the acceptance myth mora now as i've
indicated previously declining this myth
mora
the best way to do that is to play
knight f6 that transposes the game into
the allopin
into a very reputable line of the alpine
this move
simply allows us to grab our grab the
pawn and get a huge center and just get
a big advantage out of the opening
[Music]
okay so a6 he's playing some sort of a
night or like
setup but this is already asking for
trouble so all we need to do here is
develop our pieces
some people i think would be tempted to
go a4 here to stop b5 that is a sensible
move
a case could be made for that but we
don't really need to stop b5 it's not
such a dangerous idea
all we want to do here for now is to
develop our knights knight c3
knight f3 um
and he goes b5 okay so
in terms of this bishop on f1 how should
we
well where should we position the bishop
we don't have that many choices
should we even develop that bishop
should we develop the other one
yeah so we should definitely go bishop
d3 and lend
further support to the e4 pawn because
if we go bishop b2 not only is it more
passive
but the move b4 becomes very nasty and
then the e4 pawn could get loose
also bishop b7 would come with tempo
because it would attack the pawn so
bishop d3
we talked about this yesterday uh it's
almost like a prophylactic move you're
already defending the pawn so that
bad stuff can't happen to it etc etc
all right thank you scooter and he
finally settles down to think bishop b7
okay so he plays a pretty sensible setup
there's nothing
horribly wrong with how he's playing but
he's gonna have to be extremely careful
okay so the first thing to understand is
thank you phil ixz is he threatening b4
is that a threat
and let me tell you straight away that
the answer to that is no
there is a conceptual reason that it's
not a third but there is also a specific
reason that it's not a threat if he
plays before
we have an important tactical resource
in response
we can win it with the queen we can play
queen a4 check for king
the pawn and the queen and the king now
in response to that he could play knight
c6
and after the game i'll delve into the
details unless he plays
unless he plays before here we can
castle um
but knight c6 loses the game there too a
very pretty tactical sequence
okay goes knight b ds knight b to d7
okay so i think some of you are rearing
to go
and excited to play e5 e5 is premature
unfortunately and the reason is that
after d
e d e who can tell me
[Music]
you know what very nasty uh tactical
move black has there
that e5 well it loses upon him
potentially even a piece black plays
bishop takes f3
uh you know removing the defender of the
pawn and if queen takes f3 then we walk
into a fork
on top of that so we're gonna have to
take with a pawn
so we're not ready for e5 yet but that's
okay so
that doesn't mean we can't prepare e5
and that doesn't mean we can't support
this pawn further
so what would be a good way to do all of
that at the same time
yeah rookie one continue developing
eyeing e5 now
he goes e6 this guy is good he's setting
up his position in a very good way
um so he's going to be slightly worse
here but but he's managed to avoid the
worst of it so
we're just going to have to settle in
for the long haul all right so now this
bishop can be developed to a wide
variety of squares
but before we do that this this move
before now becomes a headache it becomes
a serious headache because queen a4 is
no longer a check
so a move that a lot of players hesitate
to make because it looks a little bit
lame
but let's eliminate the headache we have
the luxury of doing that because
we have the center we have a very solid
position we have a couple of tempe
despair
so bishop b7 now we can develop both to
f4 and to g5
again i think a case could be made for
both moves but
which one should be preferred i prefer
f4
as we already discussed this move loses
a lot of its effectiveness
when it doesn't pin the knight in
addition this pawn on d6 is a bit
bit tender so let's begin to harass it
just a little bit
okay now we have one more improving move
that we should make just
as a matter of bringing our pieces into
the game what am i talking about
rook c1 yep very unoriginal simple
healthy chess and there's one more move
just one more move that we should make
just to eliminate any headaches in the
future
this is a move you make if you have the
luxury of making it
and that is the move h3 not only does it
create some lift
but in the in the event of a move like
knight h5 the bishop kind of london
style could drop back to h2 so
not not forced not necessarily okay h6
now h6 is a mistake h6 is a mistake
because remember
black is a lot more passive than we are
so
our attacking capabilities in this
position are far greater than blacks
there is a very classic tactical id in
this position you've seen me play this a
million times
uh in in games against other gm's this
is a hook
that bishop on f4 is staring right at
the pawn so
immediately your tactical alarm bell
should start ringing
now sacrificing on h6 immediately is
premature clearly
but we can prepare it we go up to d2 we
build a battery
and we are ready to sacrifice on h6 if
the conditions are right but rookie 8 is
good
now this guy is this guy's finding some
uh finding some good moves despite
playing instantly
so let me think for a second
yeah i actually have to calculate unlike
him okay so there's something very
interesting let's sack
let's sack let's sack on h6
okay now the the the
reason rookie 8 is a genius move is
because after queen takes h6 he can drop
his bishop to f8 and
refi and keto it and bring pieces into
the defense
but before taking on h6 there is a
reason that we put the bishop on d3
and that is to do what
we can play e5 open up the bishop attack
the knight
and now queen takes h6 is going to come
with far greater effect assuming he
moves the knight
uh which would be uh which would be
suicidal because then we take on h6 and
you know this is totally crushing
but i'll put it this way this sacrifice
is dubious
i wouldn't do this against the gm but
i'm trying to showcase some of the
attacking ideas here i'm sure the
computer is laughing at me right now
let's see how he deals with the you know
the concrete problems that are facing
him
so i try to be as a general rule i try
to play soundly but
you know sometimes you can bend the
rules a little bit because this is an
idea that i really want to
illustrate it's dubious i'll show you
after the game
a couple of assuming he doesn't find a
good defense at night h7 i think is not
the way
now obviously in the interest of time
i'm just going to take on h thinking a
night of faith
not a bad idea actually he's not going
gentle to that good night
so how do we attack from this position
what should we do
well um first we should identify the
sources of danger where are the threats
going to come from
one of the ideas he has is to play
bishop g5 and involves queen
so that's a pretty dangerous idea
and that's a very dangerous idea
actually let me think
okay so the way that we can deal with
that idea is simply by taking on d6
by taking on d6 we are forcing him to
either take with a bishop or the queen
and in doing so uh he's going to
basically kill his own battery if that
makes sense
okay yeah well if he goes bishop f6 he's
gonna also have to reckon with
this potential idea forking both of his
rooks
so i don't think that's very much that's
particularly sustainable
okay bishop g5 okay
so i believe that that's a mistake and
it's a mistake for a very beautiful
reason well
very beautiful for a nice reason we take
on g5 and i hope he takes to the queen
or i also could have i made a slight
inaccuracy here i made a slight
inaccuracy
but he he should take with the knight
here which is
a very difficult move to make after
playing bishop g5 because the whole idea
is to take with the queen
wow okay i should have taken on h7 first
but that's okay
i think we're still in good shape
let's just think about what to do here
yeah so there's many good moves in this
position i think
um there's many good moves in this
position
but i think the most okay so this is a
little bit hard for me to explain
because there's a lot of concrete lines
here
some of you are seeing rookie five but
rookie five amazingly he's got f6
now let me walk you through it this way
the first move i saw is h4
attacking the knight but after h4 the
knight can drop back to h7 but that's
the only square the knight has
now why does h set why is h7 available
to him it's because this
incredibly annoying knight on f8 is
securing
the h7 square so hypothetically if there
was a way to distract the knight from
f8 then h4 would literally trap the
knight
so we go d7 queen can't take the pawn
because we take the knight uh with check
and if knight takes d7 then we go either
h4 or even
f4 uh both moves seem pretty good but h4
seems a little bit less exposing
and we win the night back and we're
going to be up a couple of pawns
so this is not a not a simple idea at
all but i think
i was able to walk you guys through the
logic it's very nice and that's why i
said
leaving this pawn on d6 is going to be a
pretty big mistake because we're going
to have some idea that involves using
the pawn as a
decoy the strain on his position is just
too much
there's too much going on uh and his
pieces are not quite capable of dealing
with it now this is not winning
and what a great what a gm would do is
go like knight f3 or knight h3
basically the logic is like if you're
already losing your knight you might as
well
ruin white's structure with it but the
problem is if he goes knight f3
we take on f3 and we open up the g file
so that
could result in black getting checkmated
unless he's very very careful
so we'll see knight f8 okay he doesn't
do it that's not a bad move either okay
so let's take
i gotta play a little bit faster oh he
finds queen before now that's definitely
the best line
okay now one thing i'm seeing
immediately is the idea of lifting the
knight up to f6 but unfortunately
it doesn't quite work because there's a
bishop on b7 that's guarding that square
so what idea stems from that what idea
should we note down
in case we get a chance to use it how do
we modify this idea to make sure that
this bishop is eliminated we can play
bishop before
hoping for bishop takes knight takes but
he doesn't have really a choice he can't
he's going to have to go for the bishop
trade one way or another
and so that's something that we
immediately note down other ideas notice
how i'm already looking for ideas on his
turn
so that i can make my move more
efficient there's a classic idea of the
rook lift rook e3 rook h3
if he doesn't take the pawn that would
be a good idea if he does
that doesn't come fast enough because
his queen swings back to g7
all right d5 would block the diagonal
that's also interesting
g6 is another idea using this pawn to
crack open his king's side so
okay rook c7 that's definitely too slow
and um yeah so
i like the idea bishop e4 i think bishop
b4 might be the strongest
might be the strongest idea of all of
the ones i've mentioned because
it's most immediate he allows the knight
takes d4 now the night's coming to f6
and the game is over
the knight is coming to f6 and he will
not be able to stop the lobster pins are
made
and i'll explain you know there's a lot
to unpack here
yeah so d5 would not have been quite as
good because after ed
while we have succeeded in blocking the
diagonal now the pawn fulfills the duty
of the bishop and
securing the fourth square
all right so knight h7
he's trying his best to defend
what should we do is knight f6 still
possible should we play it
yeah we should definitely play knight f6
of course knight f6 gf
and queen g7 is unstoppable other than
with uh
giving up his queen so we could have
also taken the rook first but this is
more
efficient and it's over lobster time
classic lobster fencer mate on g7
unstoppable
very nicely done by my opponent though
that was very well defended
uh for a long time and uh
you know that was close
but ultimately yeah so he find he plays
it but doesn't matter
you can see um
okay so rook takes c7 makes sense now d5
is good to open the e file thank you for
the sub tk642
yeah d5 is very oh queen d8 also wins
the rock yeah let's just win the rock
queen d.a just wins the rook and he
resigns
i have things under control for sure but
you know i'll explain why i wouldn't go
for this against the gm
okay so 1700 has been reached very nice
let's have a look at the game and i'll
call it a night
so the smith borah i have a very high
opinion of the smith morrow
i have a very high opinion of mark
esterman's book on the smith mora so if
you're looking for
a you know gunpowder repertoire
you know if you're looking for something
that fits your aggressive needs i i'm
very much uh i don't have his book but
i've i've read expert excerpts from and
i know he's a very good analyst
so mayhem and the moor is a great book
um mark's definitely the authority in
the mora
now obviously there there are lines that
black has in the accepted more that
equalize
famously logos are uh found an
interesting way
to deal with the more it doesn't refute
it but uh black certainly equalizes
there's no doubt about that
but i've never accepted the mora i i
never have had this position with black
because i i hate playing against it um
or or i have
many many years ago but ever since i
became a master i've always declined the
mora
and you can decline the mora in one of
several ways you can play knight f6
that's my recommended move
that transforms the game into the alpine
or
you can play d3 this is not quite as
good but it is a very solid line and it
leads to a very positional type of
struggle
white generally goes c4 and gets this
like marotzi bind type structure so this
position resembles a merotzi bind
i've played this a couple of times over
the board with black black is solid here
but slightly worse
now the difference between here and the
danish well the difference is that
black's
black hasn't moved his pawn he's moved
to cpun instead
so you don't play bishop c4 or that's
that's not what you do that's uh
that's like a sicilian danish but that
that's no longer as effective because
blacks
central pawns are intact okay
um let me see
so yeah the smith war is a classic
opening where
players at the top don't play it and so
you might think well what's wrong with
it and nothing is wrong with it it's not
been refuted
and even if you don't end up playing
this myth moral learning it
and understanding the ideas can be a
very very good shortcut
uh to getting better at attacking and
understanding sacrifices so
again um mark didn't pay me to say this
we had a match in the more but i
uh i'm a big fan of this opening for for
many different reasons
now d6 is another way of declining it
which is not terrible
but clearly black is going to be worse i
mean he's giving us the
full control of the center and uh he's
giving us
very nice peace development so you know
it black is not losing here like this is
not a disaster
but we have a very pleasant position
okay
so nice c3 knight f6
knight f3 b5
um and b5 is a is a nice move i like the
way he handled this
and in retrospect it might have made
sense to play a4 i don't love
playing this move you know it creates a
little hole on b4 and stuff
but maybe it made sense to prevent b5
that's just one thing to consider
knight f3 b5 bishop d3 so we get our
bishop out
in order to support the four pawn
thank you i love hearing that tk thank
you for the sub earlier bishop b7
and again in such positions on every
move you have to start asking yourself
the question
do i want to play e5 do i want to strike
in the center
and here the answer is no because
it doesn't do all that much d takes e5 d
takes e5 and whenever you push a central
pawn there's a square that is left
behind
in this case the square is d5 knight d5
black is fine
um and then black has cement the outpost
or the e6
white could try something like e6 here
sacrificing the pawn to slow down the
development of black's bishop but
i felt like this was a little bit over
the top
but you could definitely have a look at
it on your own with a computer
uh maybe e5 was in fact the way to
punish this
can you show us what you do after b4
before where before here
oh yeah so b4 here you go queen a4 check
and this is easy this just wins the pawn
because knight c6 is not possible
before here queen a4 check knight c6
who can tell me white's best move
this is a classic application of you
know the sam shanklin question not
moving the knight from c3 just because
it's being attacked go d5
easy to calculate bc dc and uh you're
threatening c7 you're threatening the
bishop
white is just totally crushing here so
that's pretty simple
but even if you didn't have this move i
mean just moving the knight is fine
this pawn now becomes a very big
weakness
um so knight c6 was not possible here i
assume you're asking why because if
queen takes c6 just take the knight
that square is not defended okay
so rookie one uh we decided to play e6
that's a good move now black can still
play b4 here
um and if you have an understanding of
the smith mora
i think it's easier to play these types
of positions with white
what i would have done here there's two
approaches you can take a very
positional approach
and you can make a move here that's
going to look terrible to most people
that's just to drop the knight back to
b1
now what's the motivate what's the logic
here well
again something i said earlier is
important which is that our position is
under
no immediate duress we've got the center
the center is well defended black's
development is okay but quite passive
and so
we can afford the luxury of rerouting
our pieces as we see fit
so as many of you are indicating the
move b4 creates
a somewhat of a hole on c4
it creates an entire complex of
weaknesses that surround the pawn and
the pawn itself
is quite weak itself so everything
around the pawn as well as the pawn is
weak
and that knight on b1 after
preliminarily developing the bishop
so this move doesn't block it we can get
the knight over to c4
or we can get the knight over to b3 uh
and potentially even stick that knight
on a5
so moving pawns like this on the queen
side unless you have a very compelling
reason to do so
can backfire in a very big way i don't
know if that makes sense
so um
one moment
so um knight d5 is the tactical approach
knight b1 is the positional approach
and the point of the tactical approach
okay
is that we sacrifice upon what do we get
in return for the pawn well we clearly
we get the e file
and what's killing black here is the
fact that he he hasn't developed his
king side
so white can literally just jump on him
and i don't think black's gonna be able
to
uh to carry his king away from the
center so what move seems very logical
here
yeah knight g5 knight u5 is just a
classic way
of attacking and then queen h5 and
you're just converging on black here
and um this is crushing this is i mean
even without analyzing anything this
just seems
totally overwhelming okay so
you have a positional approach you have
a tactical approach now i probably
wouldn't even take this knight if i were
black
i would either go e6 and just jettison
the pawn or
uh maybe go a5 first to defend it
although that is
kind of um that is
kind of iffy so rookie one he goes e6
we go a3 now we stop b4 because it's not
the b4 was dangerous
i just want to eliminate the headache of
having to deal with it on every move
oh that's more than the rare occasion so
bishop f4 h3 rook c1 roxy at h3 this is
all normal
and now h6 and again
when you develop passively you have to
be a lot more careful about making these
types of passive move
about making these types of weakening
moves and if i were black i would play
rookie 8 here instead
and after rookie a h6 becomes a lot more
doable
because for example let's make a random
move for white
after h6 queen d2 here black can
successfully parry the threat of bishop
takes h6 with what move
yeah so bishop f8 simply and the bishop
x-ray defends the h6 pawn so bishop h6
is no longer effective you can't take
with the queen
so um there was a question about
pawn breaks e5 and d5 well as i said
earlier you should
you should be aware of the concept you
should consider these pawn breaks on
every move
now although you shouldn't obsess over
it and e5 was bad previously
is bad for the same reason yeah you're
absolutely right queen d2
is what i would have played here after
rookie 8 we would have played queen d2
and then black can play bishop f8 so
it's not like black needs to play h6 or
as he's gonna
not be able to survive but this setup is
good anyway because now the rook is sort
of
participating in the game and it's just
a nice solid setup for black you can try
knight b6 later
the game goes on now the problem is
uh with the movie e5 as it was
previously we are giving
very nice this very nice uh square on d5
so ded knight d5
black's got such a solid bishop here
good diagonal y doesn't gain anything
other than a little bit of space
and the move d5 in the same in the same
vein just meets with e5 and i'm not sure
that closing up the position is
necessarily good for white
so you want to consider these moves
uh carefully but um
you you know you don't want to obsess
over it sometimes just keeping the
status quo is going to be the best
uh general option and i like this plan
bishop b1 queen d3 building up a battery
that's one of the plans that white can
consider here in order to
eventually threaten the movie 5. okay
so h6 queen d2 rookie 8 we made the
decision to take
first of all i hope it makes sense why
taking i think is bad because bishop f8
happens
we only have one check the bishop is a
crucial defender here
and once he moves his knight aside his
queen is going to participate in the
defense
so i'm just not sure that white's got
enough resources here
um but the movie five first involves the
bishop and attacks the knight
so after d takes c5d takes e5 which i
would have played i would have taken on
e5 first
and one of the things that i would have
considered here for black and this is
something that you'll see often in the
games of gm's
is as soon as a piece is sacrificed you
have to have the awareness
that you are holding a very valuable
bargaining chip you can sacrifice the
piece
back uh when the time is right
in order to uh advantageously end the
attack
so a piece is a very big deal and i
think that black can do this in one of
two different ways thank you paccos for
the sixth month the first
is to play bishop takes f3 okay
so the point of this move is not to hold
on to the extra piece white can play ef6
bishop f6 and gf3 and white's restored
material equality
but the problem is that looking look at
white's king now look at the pawn
structure
and if you're very tactically sharp you
will notice that the queens are in a
standoff
and black is the one who can exploit
that standoff to his favor
with 95 and all of a sudden white is in
big trouble
the bishop is hanging you're threatening
a royal fork a family fork
i don't think white can hold on here
rookie three there's bishop g5 there's
all these pins
so that would be one thing i would
consider and if i were white here i
would play g takes f3 i wouldn't take
the knight
but at the very least black can simply
play knight takes e5
insisting on giving the piece away rook
takes you sorry
rook takes e5 in a very simple zen move
such as bishop f8
with the aforementioned idea of
rerouting the bishop seems to be very
good for black i think black is better
here
i don't think white is nearly losing or
anything like that but
it seems like black is now firmly in the
driver's seat
another idea sorry another idea
in much the same vein is to go knight to
c5 basically immediately trying to
exploit
the queen standoff and force a trait of
queens which is advantageous for black
is now black as the two bishops
so white has to defend the bishop you
can move it and
at the very least black trades queens
and black's got an amazing end game here
with excellent piece activity
so what i was relying on is that my
opponent wouldn't
it wouldn't occur to my opponent to give
back the extra piece
so quickly after he's accepted the
sacrifice
right and that's an idea that you should
always hold on to
uh it's sometimes never too early to
give back the extra piece
if you're giving it back for a very good
reason
and that's a very common misconception
that well my opponent sacrificed a piece
so
you know now i have an extra piece and i
have to hold on to it
you actually don't you can give it away
if the situation the conditions are
right
knight h7 is a mistake queen takes h6
and knight tf8 this is an interesting
defensive setup but i don't think it
quite passes muster
so e takes d6 right now
if he would have taken on d6 then
he is no longer threatening the move
queen g5 or bishop g5 so the queen on h6
is a lot safer now than it was
previously and i have time
to accumulate my attacking force so one
idea here is to go bishop e4
bishop takes e496 or you should already
be familiar with this idea from the game
and the game continues now remember the
white has two pawns for the pieces that
we've not sacrificed a piece for nothing
we have two pawns so even if the attack
backfires
we will have something to fall back on
not ideal but we will not be completely
losing
so for example roxy won rook c1 and the
game continues i think the position is
quite unclear here
white's got excellent attacking chances
but at the same time you know we're
nowhere close to delivering checkmate
all right so the position here is very
very interesting
and i would invite you to analyze it on
your own or the computer
that would be a great way to build up
your attacking capabilities
okay just making sure
you guys are getting it i feel like
nobody said anything in like a minute
um
people's okay great oh it's stuff only
yeah let's let's eliminate sub only
oh yeah oh yeah let's i think it's okay
bruce i i can see some people are like
trolling and stuff but
since it's the speed run i want people
to be able to ask questions
yeah just behave guys don't give bruce a
hard time
when we're doing the speed run no
spamming no trolling it's like we're all
and 99 of people are uh
are are abiding by this but
uh it's important that we keep the the
educational flow going
okay um yeah hyping me up is also
is always is always a welcome as well
all right uh so i hope that makes sense
bishop d6 bishop b4 etc
now he plays bishop g5 and this leads to
some very very cool complications
so at this point i recognized that this
idea of d7
could come in very very handy and
after knight takes g5 i was hoping he
would play queen's hd5 so i would have a
chance to show a very instructive idea
so what should white do here and this
the entire attack would fail if not for
this idea
and this idea is quite instructive so
let's deconstruct the logic right
everybody should see
that the idea of d7 could be very very
strong if you could somehow eliminate
the knight from f8
if you could deal with the threat of
checkmate you would play d7 and win one
of the rooks
so immediately what comes to mind will
let's take and play d7 but no the knight
is still on f8
you just take on d7 but you can play the
intermediate move
bishop takes h7 check then take the
queen
and then play d7 and you will end up
being up in exchange in a bunch of pots
right yeah deflection is right what's up
salty clan
so that's why he should have taken the
pawn leaving a pawn like this intact
is just a bad idea and by the way
if he would have played bishop takes f3
here of course we would have taken his
bishop first and then taken on f3
it's too late for you it's too late for
black to
give back the extra piece that the train
the opportunity train is
has left the station so bishop g5 knight
g5 he plays knight g5
but now i think an even nicer idea we
still go d7
and there's a kind of reverse logic to
that there
we were trying to distract a knight that
controlled d7
so we were trying to distract that
knight and get it to h7
now we're doing the opposite we are
trying to distract the knight that
controls h7
and getting it to move on to d7 because
the idea
is different we're now trying to hit
this knight
and uh remove its capability of coming
back to h7
which it had if we would have played h4
and the order matters if we go d7 now
and say no problem now let's distract
the knight no
you can't do that anymore now queen
takes d7 as possible
it's the fact that black's queen is
overloaded
which makes this move possible d7 so i
talked about this a lot in the
five-minute speed run
the concept of type one and type two
undefended pieces
and i i haven't talked about it as much
in the 10-minute speed run but i'll just
review this concept for the people who
are new to my lectures and stuff thank
you curious for the five
so type one and type two undefended
pieces type one undefended piece
is a piece that is not 500 by young 42
that is not protected by
any other pieces so technically a bishop
on b7 is a type 1 undefended piece but
but a type 2 undefended piece is a piece
that is protected by
only one other piece and pawns don't
count if
if a piece is protected by a pawn then
it's defended so the knight on g5 is a
type 2
undefended piece and those types of
pieces
can also be very very vulnerable so when
you notice the queen making contact with
the knight
the queen is not a very good defender
because it's generally easy to distract
and that's exactly what we do here d7
queen can't take because of queen g5 he
takes for the knight
h4 and the knight is trapped i think
that he should have gone queen f6 that
was the last chance
big bad boris with a five oh my gosh
this is crazy
thank you this is getting ridiculous
but we just take on g5 and we're up what
we're up two pawns
in the end game this is technically
winning protect me winning position
he collapses with knight f8 now we go
bishop b4 and we're paving the way for
the knight to come to f6 now i have one
last thing to share on this position
thank you big bad boris once again for
the five
if he would have taken and gone rook
takes rook
what is white's fastest path to
checkmate what is what's
quickest path to mate
so finally it's just a funny line that
f6
and you're being cute here but this is
funny he's got two rooks in a night but
he can't defend against
the all-mighty lobster pins are made
that's the
that's the power of that you can have
all sorts of pieces you could add a
bishop on d5 and
you could even add a queen somewhere on
a4 you could add a queen on a4
and it would still be well no actually
that would black would have a defense
but
you get the point you get the point